foreign
s here wanted to be part of this story
so they braved the rain in their droves
many spending a damp night on the
concrete I think it's just like you know
British culture it wouldn't be Britain
unless everyone was out here in the rain
it's a huge celebration and everyone's
coming together and marking this moment
in history it's great worth the early
start absolutely
they knew they were in for something
particularly special we've been here for
the all the Queen's funeral and then the
weddings and the happy times and sad
times it's a happy day isn't it one they
wanted to witness share and enjoy
a day of Celebration that spanned
Generations
[Music]
we just saw the king with the carriage
Rosie James and Henry's grandmother was
18 months old during the Queen's
coronation she's now passing on the
tradition
my older sister was in she was dressed
in a Union Jack Flag dress and lots of
Street parties and I mean my parents and
with from East London and I absolutely
love the Royal Family Protection both
here and ever though some watched the
service on small screens many prefer to
just listen and be present offering
their support to their new king he's
gonna be a good King he's uh he's gonna
be a good leader for this uh country the
treats for the eyes eventually came when
they caught a glimpse of gold
we've had the carriages we've had the
military and now it's the turn of the
people this will be the first time
they'll get to greet and welcome the new
king and queen this is the moment
they've been waiting for
[Music]
and we didn't think we're gonna get that
close so we were really really tough
this is my Christmas present from my
husband a flight home child free to come
and see the coronation and then look
where we end up
a journey worth making for a crowd that
partied in the rain and can now say they
had a spot on the very front row of
History cheers